oh great you scared him away oh she
looked you didn't scare him away
yeah you hiding scared away you scared
him away
let's finish this book first then we'll
have that book the royal family
is missing archie and all his cuteness
especially with the upcoming holidays
a source close to meghan markle and
prince harry tells et
it's fully anticipated that the family
of three will spend christmas at home in
california
rather than return to the uk as for the
couple's
specific plans the source says nothing's
been finalized
just yet i'm a california girl according
to our source
royal family members are disappointed
they won't be seeing archie
yet again this holiday season last year
the duke and duchess of sussex skipped
christmas at sandringham
with the queen instead opting to spend
extended family time with megan's mom
doria ragland in canada and although the
queen paid tribute to archie
in her annual christmas day address 200
years on from the birth of my
great-great-grandmother queen victoria
prince philip and i have been delighted
to welcome
our eighth great-grandchild into our
family her
appearance snub of megan and harry by
leaving them out of the family photo
tribute
on her desk a seemingly small and
insignificant step
overlooked by many was anything but
small insignificant
or overlooked by royal fans
in other royal family news remember when
prince charles got kovid 19
shortly after almost forgetting to
follow the no handshake protocol
at the prince's trust awards in march
and i find myself on the other
side of the illness but still in
no less a state of social uh distance
and and general isolation
luckily the 71 year old symptoms were
relatively mild
and he's since recovered and returned to
work
but we're now learning he wasn't the
only royal to contract the virus
there is obviously some concern about
who charles came into contact with now i
was with the royals on
commonwealth day service now charles was
there with the queen
with the cambridges and with the
sussexism here's what the palace
revealed about the queen's health at the
time
i've been told by buckingham palisades
the queen has showed
no symptoms of any illness she's in fit
fine health and we are all hoping
and therefore that um that the queen is
not
at risk of becoming ill as a result of
having seen her son
fans assumed the cambridges were coveted
free too
we do not know and have not been told if
they have been tested for coronavirus
they would only be tested if they were
showing symptoms and potentially they
would have to be tested privately
because
the nhs has very strict guidelines on
who it is testing
william and kate are much younger and
wouldn't be tested on the nhs unless
they were showing very severe symptoms
so they are self-isolating at anima
with the children but now a source tells
et that prince william got covered in
april
and kept the news private the source
also adds that the future king
actually had fairly significant symptoms